Speaker 1: It is back, folks. The U.S. will
require negative COVID tests for travelers coming
from China after more than half of a plane load of
passengers from China to Italy tested positive for
COVID. Does it work to require incoming travelers
to test? Well, we'll talk about that in a moment.
NPR reports. U.S. will require travelers from
China to show negative COVID tests before flight.
This will apply to travelers from China, Hong Kong
and Macao to show a negative COVID test before
entering the United States. The CDC announced the
measure yesterday. It will go into effect January
five for all passengers over age two. Passengers
must show a negative PCR or monitored antigen test
no more than two days before departure. Whether
it's a direct flight or whether you're coming
from another country, if you go China, London, New
York, you would still have to show such a test,
even though, strictly speaking, your flight is
coming into the U.S.. From London, the monitor
test must be overseen by a telehealth service. CDC
is pointing to the surge in COVID cases in China
and the, quote, lack of adequate and transparent
epidemiological and viral genomic sequence data
being reported from that country, quote, reduced
testing and case reporting in China and minimal
sharing of viral genomic sequence data could delay
the identification of new variants of concern if
they arise. So there's a few different things
that I think are important to talk about here.
And one of the things that I want to just remind
people when it comes to transparency from China,
if you look right now at the official reports of
data from China, China since the start of the PAN,
we're talking three years, folks, China is
officially reporting that they've had only
400,000 COVID cases and only 5200 deaths.
You would have to be living under a rock and
suffering from serious confusion to believe that
these numbers are even remotely connected to the
reality of COVID in China. Another interesting
thing, if you look at the official data,
China is starting to report higher case numbers,
but never more than 5000 cases a day, and yet they
have not officially reported any deaths since
May. So it is absolutely correct that the data
we're getting from China is bogus. And if you look
at just a little anecdote, The Hill reports nearly
half of passengers from China to Milan have COVID.
Look at this. Nearly half of the passengers on
two recent flights to Milan from China tested
positive, 38% of passengers on one flight and
52% of those on a second flight had COVID. There
is no way. That the entire country of China with
a population of is at 1.3 billion at this point,
1.4 billion people. There's no way they have only
four or 5000 cases a day and no deaths. If half of
two random flights from China to Italy are people
who have COVID. So 100%. It is correct to believe
that there is a crazy amount of COVID coming out
of China. Now, the question is, does requiring
entry COVID tests work? You know, the idea is
you require people to test to come in. You
identify people who should immediately go
into quarantine and hopefully you prevent the
spread? Yes. I mean, the idea makes some sense.
The difficulties are many, the supervised antigen
tests. Remember when I was in Spain last summer,
my girlfriend that I did these supervised
antigen tests where it's just a home test,
but someone watches you do it. And my girlfriend
got two false positives and she was negative. We
ended up having to find a hospital on a Sunday
Catholic holiday in Spain, which I can tell you
is very difficult to do. Get a PCR. Turned
out she was. It turned out she was negative.
Those tests are not the most accurate. But
not only are false positives a problem,
false negatives, particularly in asymptomatic
people, are a major, major problem. In fact,
when I had COVID a few weeks ago, I was testing
negative on those tests, even though I had
COVID until I don't even know, I guess, day
three of my symptoms. So the limitations are
asymptomatic. People often test negative on those
tests. It's not a guarantee you're not infected.
The fact that you can get the test two
days before travel makes it particularly
unhelpful. The incubation period of COVID, even
though, you know, if you look at the bell curve,
most people start showing symptoms between 2 to 5
days after exposure. It can be up to ten or even
more days. So is that a reason not to do anything?
No, but it is a reason why the technique may not
be that effective. To be perfectly frank,
the most effective part of requiring testing
for people coming from China is it might dissuade
people who are carrying the virus from even coming
to the United States at all. But the the real
effectiveness of that policy is a question mark,
I think is the point doesn't mean we shouldn't do
anything, doesn't mean we shouldn't be concerned.
But we have to be sort of realistic about that,
about that strategy. Let me know your thoughts.
Let me know if your perspective is changing
on sort of like your risk tolerance at this
point. And of course, you immediately will get the
debate over. This will inevitably be what happens
in the United States because it's happening now in
China versus it might not be. China has a very low
level of immunity as a result of their zero-covid
policy. And so it's not necessarily the case that
what we see in China is going to happen in the
United States remains to be seen. Make sure you're
subscribed on YouTube YouTube.com slash The David
Pakman Show. We're going to take a quick break
and be right back with so much more to start
winding down 2022. I would love for you. Yes,
you. I'm really talking to you. To sign up
on our Web site. Join Pacman dot com. We do
depend directly on the support of our viewers and
listeners to do the show that we do. And we do an
extra show every single day for our members.
You can sign up at join Pacman dot com and not
only get the bonus show but also get commercial
free audio and video streams of the show hours
before anybody else gets them. We also have our
next members only town hall coming up soon. I'll
be making an announcement about that. And as
a member, you will get exclusively invited to
participate and talk to me in that town hall sign
up at join Pacman dot com it'll take you I mean
with average like computer skills it's probably
45 to 60 seconds to sign up and quite frankly,
it's probably no more than a minute and a half,
even with mediocre tech skills. So I encourage
you to do it. You can use the coupon code 24
starts now to get yourself a sizable discount.